images of modern warfare 2's multiplayer
has surfaced online and the new pokemon
game is bringing us back to school to
hunt for treasure
call of duty modern warfare 2 was
officially revealed back in june with a
ton of details regarding the campaign
narrative and new game mechanics but
details are still scarce on the game's
multiplayer modes however it seems like
nfl players from the los angeles rams
have gotten hands-on time with the game
and have also leaked some images that
appear to confirm modern warfare 2's
longed rumored dmz mode a kicker for the
team shared an image of the game's menu
on instagram stories and captioned the
image quote having fun on the new call
of duty another player posted a slightly
blurry photo saying they were previewing
the unreleased game but the image still
clearly says dmz in the top right hand
corner of the screen the images have
since been deleted but sites like
charlie intel and modern warzone were
quick to capture and tweet out their
existence call of duty insiders have
long suggested the existence of dmz
which is said to be a modern warfare 2
extraction based mode inspired by escape
from tarkov in open world mode with a
mix of battle royale and survival game
elements that has reportedly been in
development for four years it was also
rumored that dmz might be set for a
standalone release in 2023 but the rams
players have seemingly confirmed that
the new mode is packaged alongside the
campaign multiplayer and spec ops modes
that are already confirmed by infinity
ward more information is set to come
this weekend as the call of duty league
announced members of infinity ward will
share new information during vanguard's
call of duty league championship on
august 7th viewers will also have a
chance to score modern warfare 2 beta
codes during sunday's championship game
but modern warfare 2 isn't the only big
game we're all going to be playing this
fall and today the pokemon company
revealed more details about its november
games pokemon scarlet and pokemon violet
the game takes place in the paldea
region which players will travel across
using the two legendary pokemon the
trailer also shows off how versatile
those legendaries are both can be used
for travel by air land and sea the story
centers on a pokemon academy where the
main character is a student who sets out
to explore the world but that's not all
because we also learn about scarlet and
violet's new gameplay mechanic
terrastolyze which transforms the pocket
monster into a crystal version of itself
with boosted stats i really wish they
named it something else crystallized
bling mode anything terrastilize that's
gonna take forever every time i go to
say it i have to pause and like think
about it first each pokemon in the
paldeo region gets a unique gem-like
look when subjected to terrestrializing
and some pokemon will change type as
well according to the pokemon company
there are 18 types that will form a wide
number of combinations of pokemon and
terror types and players can
terrastilize a pokemon once per battle
afterwards the terror orb used for that
transformation will need to be recharged
by touching crystals overflowing with
terrestrial energy or by going to a
pokemon center there's also the
opportunity to take part in terror raid
battles when four other players team up
to take on a terrastilized wild pokemon
so now that we have this new bling mode
because that's what i'm gonna call it
from now on don't we need a new name for
shiny pokemon because like these are the
real shiny pokemon so i feel like we
should have a new name for the old type
of shiny pokemon let me know what you
think they should be called and also
rename terrastilizing mode i'm i'm
dubbing it bling mode but
give it a name for yourself and let me
know that in the comments too and i'll
see you tomorrow
oh and pokemon company don't think i
forgot all right yesterday i said i
wanted to see two things more
information on co-op you showed co-op
but where's pokemon sleep huh
i haven't slept since you announced it
where is it
you